ouais on va démarrer très fort un mais
sans relief mais regardez-moi se relooke
[Musique]
vous savez qu'il ya vait patron
incognito et pour la dark a donc les
chroniqueurs c'est lourd tous se sont
mis en a connu tout dans le public ouais
on va démarrer très fort un mais ça y
est t'es regardez-moi se relooke de
regarder moi ce rôle ou de raymond tu
écris je vous en remercie punch out
safari a l'air vraiment lesquels vettel
lourdeur alerte sur bernard montiel
versant des lives et dvd merci j'en ai
vu à la balle à balla balla bas gilbert
b
la la la la la la la la ara aprikian oh
là là qu'il est vilain jean michel maire
venez avec nous bon donc je vous ai
remarqué depuis le début pas la peine de
faire ce genre bien sûr matthieu
delormeau et mai sont des méchants mais
christine kelly
jarolim tommy ne vois pas du tout ça va
pas dû aller où elle est où
oui je regarde dans les rues inondées ou
n'ont pas brûlé je voulais le passer
rires oui je veux voir là encore encore
endormi alors oui encore mais ce
bouillon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce chroniqueur à tony tôt c'est de là
que dans cette émission qu'on fait un
casque à son diocèse à cache cache
mais qu'un petit budget mais quand même
tu vas on sait of others sympa mais on
est tu vois alors on a voulu faire des
trucs tout ça c'est pas mal
[Musique]